I never met you but I wanted to invite
you to the party and you walked in with
those green eyes never stolen by nobody
and they flick to the Future for a
moment I could picture then you touch me
and I come back and we're talking on the
staircase about your Big Dreams on the
big screens at a Georgia now you're
lonely in this city lying with me and
you're scared as mov moving quickly oh
now you're crying you're in pieces cuz
the only love you've ever known is Jesus
I can feel it oh ha did out the reason
that's you're in your head right
now while your world is spinning
out so it's slow it without take a
moment now we're too young to drown
deep it dirty word is full of Hope to
start let me pour you out let me hold
you now let me slow it down Ain't It
Funny I changes how the future
rearranges I get nervous or I'm anxious
maybe loving you is dangerous I can lose
you like the others only girl that's
never left me it's my mother
I love and I know you probably hate it
but I'm in my head right
now so slow it down take a moment now
with too young to down deep it dirty
word is full of Hope start let me pull
you out let me hold you now let me
slow slow it down when you're on the
ground and you're
crying I'm
trying to slow it down when you're
spinning around in your
head uh help you slow it
[Music]
down hey friends so this lovely moving
camera work was brought to us by the
lovely muasa thank you so much brother
of course yeah uh where can the good
people find you online sir all going to
check me out at Instagram and YouTube
ATO moner perfect go check this man out
his work is fantastic thanks so much bro
take care you too hey friends I hope you
enjoyed that flow and if you'd like to
get yourself a set of those orb poy Pros
that I was using in this video you're in
luck because not only are they back in
stock over at Ultra but you can also get
5% off the cost of them when you use the
code Drex Factor with a zero instead of
an O at checkout over at ultra.com once
again that is drexfactor with a zero
instead of an o thank you so much to
ultra poy for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to go out and
explore different parts of DC with my
poy and speaking of thank yous big thank
yous go out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys py light toys and Ultra
poy for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- buus friend of the
channel That is Becca beonin thank you
so very much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission finally this
video and all the videos on this channel
would not be possible without my amazing
supporters on patreon in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you all so very much and if
you out there watching like the content
that I create and you'd like to sign up
to support it you can do that by heading
on over to patreon at
patreon.com Factor Po and sign up you
can get access to some awesome rewards
but even better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to check out
more of my flow sessions I will include
a link to a playlist of those videos
down in the description as well as up on
screen thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace